yeah I know when I welcome to this video
playing big blogger Germany was a german
beer brand so she might be from the
place but also might be just a fan of
the of the beverage so we play the Kings
Indian attack let's see maybe gimme I
think he can switch back to this the
setup of course ok so he wants to
conserve this yeah he h 5 is actually
quite ridiculous move so let's not do it
ok i'm happy with having provocative
just neither six maybe even i'm not
quite sure here Scoob I have six
yeah probably go before I'm not totally
happy it was playing b6 them and I
probably have to yeah I think you will
go before the sea 39 is unprotected but
I don't really have a way to exploit
this between this very strange on c2
doesn't make don't quite know what this
does tear this one maybe you like the
five I kitchen so I can just take it but
this is very unlikely to happen I mean
it doesn't make much sense in any case
let's move this decides blundering the
piece so probably and yes something like
that ok so here I can try this and then
e 6 55 I wonder this is good this should
be six is also interesting I basically
has to take otherwise if he comes back I
will be five and this is immediately
good for black yeah interesting i can
either think about taking with the f1 to
open up the f file i know i think this
is simple and good I still threaten be
five okay so he avoids this can also go
teach fires here
[Music]
yeah so I wanted to avoid c-5m so I went
to be six foot and now I think he
basically has to take as difficult to
avoid the exchanges there on the C file
little bit surprised us III maybe no
yeah yes it's very difficult to make
something happen here
he's very click there with the exchanges
then we have time teen aged seven Bishop
age six would be good but that doesn't
look like it should work maybe I should
have done that a little bit differently
but okay it's what it is okay yeah I
cannot try a little bit at least this
ending is slightly more comfortable for
black those pawns on dark squares of
course why shouldn't lose but clear you
can try a little bit em once the goji
for me it's very difficult to do
anything against
so anyway to enter this position here
prolly not
now cannot do much here
yeah that's to draw William yeah I can
play Bishop f6 like bring it around but
still I aren't still extremely dry
ok Oh what does he do that so surprising
yes 10 kiloton hoopla cannot take I mean
he goes to the Jeep on before I don't
know if that was planned or whatever but
it works it works fun
it was entirely unnecessary to do I mean
get rid of my big default point open up
this possibility in the first place but
I cannot exploit it unfortunately King
before is a good way to lose
I have no idea what he is doing here
maybe it's not losing but he tries very
hard could have just stayed do nothing
why when I it was very strange I mean I
had absolutely nothing here white can
just stay like shuffle around and have
nothing just completely completely
George yeah actually I like this yeah
but I couldn't really get much there d 5
is given by the college that looks more
promising this was a little bits it was
too it was 222 lame this is all okay but
you're not going to get any edge okay so
which is equal what can you do extremely
equal yeah it was completely unnecessary
and wow the engine our TV for oh I
didn't think of that and my eve of
mighty porn is very quick here yeah if I
didn't see the upon learning so we both
cried ballet and now we just let me in
there for no reason can play it should
be two or whatever he has been a bad end
game under both players I didn't but I
didn't see is simply
but that I can actually get there I was
only thinking this which which seems
critical but i forgot that i can take
this and and mighty Pontius quick
because he has to take this first move
the king and so on even this is good
game i played this badly ok guys thanks
for watching